Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now, we gotta get movin' here because we got a lot of stuff that we're going to be doing today.
I'm gonna build an alien containment chamber to finally house these eggs that I've been finding and I'm going to do it in my
secondary base. Not the base I'm about to build down the deep depths of Hell;
I still have to get more materials for that, but before I go on gathering materials again, I am going to do something
that's actually useful with my time, and I'm gonna have some friends. Like who'd've thought that? Markiplier with friends?
What is this? I thought we were playing Subnautica here, but no, alas, it is true. I'm about to have some real
honest-to-goodness fish friends that I promised I won't eat, so I'm going to put the lockers up here
and I'm going to read the names off the lockers, but before I do that, I need to actually do that,
so here we freakin' go...
Okay! So the first one goes to Alex Cephon, and people have been wondering how to get names in the locker
it's really just I pull from the comments down below.
So if you want your name to accompany me down into the depths of Hell, write a comment! Give me some advice!
Make me laugh! do whatever you want, put a comment down there, so thanks guys.
But Alex says,
"The Jochi Khasar Pod is buried beneath the sand. The Pod entrance was literally just below you and you didn't realize it.
Sorry that you didn't know this before, but now you do." So thanks so much for that advice!
I might go back there.
But I'll go back there with bubble butt if I do to save some time. Next up is Samantha Schnettler
"Who said there's something FISHY about everything going on but hey,  WATER you gonna do about it? I'm SHORE you can manage,
We COD all do better, don't you think?
WHALE, I best be off. If you SEA a friend, don't forget to WAVE, and also if you think of a better fish
pun, let MINNOW." (Get it? Minnow? no? ok then)
So I'm officially going to be banning Samantha Schnettler from my YouTube comment section(RIP), because those are beyond Wade
level of puns. And the next one goes to
Astro Hard Ammo, who I'm putting here as Astrohard, "Could you not cure the Carar virus with Pepis?"
and everyone knows that cold, delicious Pepis solves all life problem. Shafatul Islam said,
"Mark, the Sea Dragon Leviathan egg is found in the disease research facility, and then you can put it in the Alien Containment chamber.
After a few days, it will hatch with a baby former of himself, then you can mess around with it,
but be careful, it could die. When the creature is hatched, it will not
attack you. Imagine to have your own pet Sea Dragon Leviathan that is not deadly.
Can't wait for it." And you will have to wait for it, because I believe that's in the dev build, and right now
I'm playing the normal game. I may go to the dev build again, and in fact I probably want to do that,
I was just fear-- ah, fuck there's rocks! Ah, shit!
I can't drive here! I'm actually gonna--oh, apparently I'm actually going to do a flyby of Jochi Khasar again,
So maybe, just maybe, I can find that Sea Pod, where that is.
But then again,
Maybe that's in the dev build of the game a-and maybe I do want to go over to the dev build. You know what?
I'm gonna do it! I've gone back and forth before, I can do this again. Why not? Hey, YOLO or something, am I right?
MMMMMMM! (Mark pls)
MMMMMM!! (No Mark)
MMMMMM! (Mark pls stop)
Whoa. Whoa!
What?
What!? Hoh, no! Ohhh... Oh.....
Oh-- ooh!
What? Damage?!
You didn't say anything about getting damaged! Oh, and I was slamming my haul all over the place!
How am I gonna be able to kill the dragon?
Okay... but wow! This-- oohh! Hoh, there have been some updates! Oh!
Oh, my God. This is beautiful actually. Holy shit. They've updated just about Goddamn everything!
Holy shit!
Oh, my God!
This is amazing. Okay, I gotta eat or something because that's about to kill me, but
holy shit. Ah, it's so pretty now! Oh, I like the unifi-- what was--
What did I just cli-- what- I- why-- the 'Decoy Loading Tu--' what do you mean the Decoy loading Tube?
What is that? I don't know what that is! Can you explain it to me?
I'm so confused. Alrighty then. I'm just gonna put these in my mouth, because I believe that still works like I think it would.
Okay, so that works. I got food inside of me, and the new user interface is just... pretty damn cool... okay?
But at least everybody's still here! Astrohard, hold on to this shit, because I'm gonna need to
go on an adventure here, so I'm just gonna...
Yeah, I'm gonna put these back in
Jonas Grav, which is where that should be but
everything seems to be good so I'm going to go out and I'm going to see if I can repair something-- that is- that is biz--
that's bizarre, there's actually an animation for that now. boy howdy, they're puttin' some polish on this bad bo- ohhh, my God!
Maybe that's what the banging was before. Let me put this over here. Oh, click-and-drag interface, I love it. Shoooop! Awww,
Sweet digs, bro. I think I got the ion battery in this bad boy. Oh, damage, let me repair you!
...Nevermind, apparently. Huah!
BLAP. Okay, so now I actually have to be careful with this son of a bitch!
I know, foreign concept for everybody out there, but uh you know, I'm gonna just try. Just try a little bit.
Not try very hard, obviously,
I don't want actually put any effort into what I do in this, but I'm gonna try! Just a little bit.
Oh, look, an O2 indicator... that I'm going to ignore, and then drown all the time
Cav- cuv- what- what did you just say?
Cavitating excessive noise?
Did you just purge the ghosts?
Holy shit! He just Ghostbusted this bitch!
Oh, my God, the whole thing listed to the side, and then we... no more ghosts!
Well, shit, all right then. So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take this out of there
and I'm gonna charge it up, because apparently we're taking a bit of power here- ooh.
Let's see... so you're normal power cells, but I thought I had
...more o' ya...
You know what? that's okay, I'm gonna just- I'm gonna trade out because I can. Oh, it looks so pretty!
It do!
It looks so pretty!
Like no joke, it looks real pretty. the only thing I don't have is a full readout of how much power my-
my thing has. It's not the top anymore, unless that green bar is it or unless it's some sort of objective way point thing.
but either way, we got oodles of power, so I'm not exactly worried about that, but
alas, we go... and apparently that's a sonar navigating system which any
self-respecting submarine would have!
That does not change our objectives, except it changes exactly our objectives. So I'm gonna go over to the Mongolian emissary and-- oh...
Well, there's my power meter. Apparen-- Oh.
...We can go faster!
...Oh, my God.
That is so cool.
If we go silent running does that mean we're not gonna disturb any of the-the people out there-- oh!
Torpedoes!? Or is that the decoy? Ah, I love it! I love this!
Okay, here we go. We're gonna cavitate and cause some noise, but we are booking it, baby!
I don't know if we're going any faster than we have in the past, but we are fuckin' bookin' it!
Emergency speed? Yeah, you're goddamn right emergency speed, but we got an assload of power in our back
So we don't even need to worry about that. So that must be the noise. So what if I....
Honk!
Hooonk! Honk!
Hoooonk!
Oh, shit, that's so cool. That's so cool-- What is that? Oh... oh...
I don't know what cavitating means,
But I'm assuming that's bad.
Also that radar screen is awesome it reminds me of the game Homeworld. Do you remember the map view of Homeworld in Homeworld 2?
How it would just zoom out and you'd see like the-the 3D representation of the map and navigation points that it would have there in?
Ooh, hey... good to know that you're still doing backflips!
And apparently, it seems to be loading a bit smoother than it has in the past. Oh, man,
I wonder what new secrets are available in the dev build. Oh, the experimental version is so cool!
Why did I ever leave? Why did I go back to release?
Why did I-- Oh that's right because my save broke and like I literally couldn't open my save anymore.
But now I'm back. Oh, I am back baby, and you are just...
Freakin' weird. Oh hi, big mushroom tree mama.
Gettin' a few low frames here, but at least you're looking good, and that's what matters. Oh, I'm gonna hit these, aren't I?
Yeeeet.. yeet, yeet!
Ah, shit!
Oh no, did I- did I do dablage [damage]? Did I do some dablage? Probably... ooh, wait, what? Did we miss Jochi?
Oh! Apparently we missed Jochi Khasar. Let's circle back. Oh, I see it now. I think I see it-- oof.
What the fuck? what the fuck is attacking me?
What the fuck was that?! what?!
What the fuck was that?
Oh, something's hanging around our ass end, and it does not like me. Oh, it's coming!
...Okay.... ah, shit-- what is attacking me? What the fuck?!
Well jeez, that's no good. We're not doing a lot of damage though, so I'm assuming. It's not like a
Leviathan or anything like that, is it?
Goddammit, stop hitting me. I'm gonna slap you. Who's slapping me?
Huh? Oh, it's just you, you little shark bastard. Well, why dont you take it up with...
Well, not me because I don't want to fight you, but why don't you take it on someone your own size?! Big Box Barry's a gentle giant.
..Just being a bully...
Leave him alone! He's a father! Oh, hi...
Hello, Lifepod of Jochi Khasar.
How are you doing? What is this? What is that?
'Open Data Box'?
Whoa... Why- I don't know what that is.
What is that?
Jochi? How you doin', bubbo?
Okay, I got a voice log. What is that?
What is that? What is that?
Oh, that's the new lithium? How am I gonna be able to know what anything is anymore? Oh, everything is garbo now!
Oh no, everything's changed. Oh, absolutely
everything has changed.
Oh, my God... ugh...
I'm gonna need a few- I may need a few minutes to wrap my head around all this bullshit. Here we go
Let's listen to the voice log, I guess-- Hey, what the fuck was that?!
What the fuck was that?!
You're just gonna be dicking with me this whole time, huh?! Jeez! Alright, anyway,
whatever.... wait-- ugh, fuck-- uh...
'Data downloads,' 'lifepod'....here we go, "Lifepod systems online."
"Passenger 07 'Emissary Jochi Khasar' has boarded the lifepod." "Lifepod launch sequence initiated."
"Lifepod detatched from the Aurora OK."
"Onboard microphone recordings: My creators, the cherishers and sustainers of worlds
give me this day my daily goods, and allow me my pleasures, as I allow those who seek pleasures from me."
Well, that's creepy and weird.
"Entering planetary atmosphere." "External temperature approaching critical levels." "Show me the path, in Life, in Truth, and Love,
in Substance, Principle, and Mind. For mine is the power, I am the one, for ever and ever, on and off and on again."
"Exterior hull damage sustained." "Life support system failed." "Impact imminent." "Life is a game, which the universe plays with itself.
I'm done pretending to merely-- be merely this bundle of flesh. I am ready to play for a different side."
Well, he was doing his death prayer, I think. I'm pretty sure that's what that was.
Huh.
Weird. So what was the thing that I got from them? Because I got something.
But... what did it mean?
Like, i-it said something about
it 'modified my crafting systems,' or something like that...?
God, I really don't know.
That's super weird. I'm gonna have to-- you guys are gonna
have to tell me about that one, because I don't know what that w-- okay,
I just pissed myself-  but I don't know what that was so I got a find that out later.
But I will get to that in a little bit. Oh,  everything looks so shiny and new...
Oh, I'm gonna drink this piss...
Okay then, then I'm going to take some more fruit,
And then I'm going to be good to go... that is going to take forever to fill that battery,
But alas, we have plenty of power with which to do dat.
Okay, and away we go!
We need to rendezvous with Bubble Butt, and then make ourselves everything that we need! And apparently, we're 'cavitating' and 'making too much noise.'
Which is going to cause us to become attacked.
Cavitating... is that something like attractivating, or- err-- bringing towards us, because apparently
nothing, nothing likes noise. Which means that suddenly, we're in danger again!
Which is both a good and bad thing because in any game that has horror elements--
and this is definitely one of them you can't say it's not-- but in any game where you remove the threats,
and you give yourself a safe harbor, like this boat that was invincible,
It becomes less threatening, and therefore less scary, but now I'm in danger
wherever I go, no matter what is out there, it might be able to kill me, and I know that this can now go a little bit faster,
but I don't think that's enough
to be able to get away from, say, a Reaper Leviathin, or a Sea Dragon, or anything of that sort,
which means that when we approach such monstrosities, we're going to have to creep as
quietly as we can...
...and try to avoid all the monsters of the deep, and I guarantee you,
in the uh, experimental build there's going to be monsters of
epic proportions that we cannot even come close to imagining-- excuse me, honky honk!
Are you the monsters of epic proportions of with which we cannot possibly imagine?
Alright, fine then, have a lovely day, don't look at me like that, you weird, weird monster.
I will not pay child support, get out of here with that bull!
Alright I'll meet you back at the base, ugh...
Oh, I see Bubble Butt! Oh, ah, uh, hey whoa, whoa, rocks!
Jesus! no one warned me about that?
I didn't get a-- oh, there it is, there's the proximity warning, Jesus.
All right... I'm aware we're cavitating. I don't know why you gotta say that such a threatening rumble!
Oh, me old base.
What a lovely place.
Oh, ooh, hey, warpy woo! Hopefully you're not gonna be a dick to me...
Okay, so I got my moon pool here.
How about you stop being such a douche. Have I got the outside floodlights? Did they fix this and make it any better?
Maybe... through the cameras definitely. Did they make the-- okay, bye then.
Did they make warper bigger? The warper looked a little bit bigger to me. Okay, so I got to go tradesies on the, uh,
the Sea Moth, and replace the, uh,
Place, uh... Mr. Fister
in there, because I'm going to be taking the Sea Moth out
And about because the Sea Moth is so flippin' fast and I kind of want to see if there's been any updates to the Sea Moth. Hello!
Oh, that's not good. Oh, that's not good. Oh, that's not go- Oh, that's- Ohh, that's NOT good...
I forgot that I didn't have a hull
modification in that. So, what I gotta do is that going to build one of those before I do anything else... Alright.
What do we need?
Plasteel and computer chip. I can do both of those things, 'cause I got all the necessary materials.
I need to make an ingot.
Baba ba ba... Do we have power? We do have power here. Man, those bio-- are- are we serious here?
Those bioreactors have been making-making-- what have they been making power out of?
'Cause, its been ages since I filled you! Oh, my God.
I don't believe that for a moment. I'm sorry, I just don't believe that!
I just- I just do not believe that you have power here, because that is a goddamn ridiculous--
You?!
There's no way that you had power!
This is a load of bullshit!
Okay, but either way, I got my plasteel ingot, and thankfully I don't need to go any deeper than just this, so I've got
Whatchamacallit... I'm making a plasteel ingot. so we gotta plasteel ingot, and then we need a computer chip
I believe all my silver is back in my, uh...
my Cyclops, so I'm gonna go for that-- splooosh! Okay.
Shloop, alrighty then! Woopty woopty. All systems are in line, thank you.
Again, why does it... every time I get in this thing?
It-it pushed me back!
Why? There's some wonky physics going on here, but then again it is experimental mode, so I guess that's to be expected.
Alright, so I need, um... I need to make a computer chip.
You got it buddy boo. I know where to do that. I've got...
...silver in here...
...And then I've got coral...
Coral!
Where's the Goddamn coral? Coral! No? Coral? Table coral?
Yeah, table coral, that's it and God, all these new icons,
I have no idea what they are, but at least they're more distinct, like
that is something that I can applaud about it,
It is definitely distinct now. Alright, so I need to make a computer chip-- oh, what?!
Gold?! Gold?!
Did they change that? They changed that, didn't they? Gold? Well, good.
Maybe that's going to be less silver required, because silver was overused, and gold was not used... you're tellin' me that shit ain't gold? Fuck you.
Gold, gold, gold, there it is.
And then what else? What else did you need... copper wires.
We need copper. Okay. Copper, copper, copper, copper wire. Which makes sense,
I don't even think it needed copper wire before, but it didn't seem to do that for the computer chips, but now
computer chip kind of makes a little bit more sense, because usually for electronics when you're connecting things,
It's usually gold that's gonna be used for that, so when they didn't have gold available
then I was a little bit confused. Did we list again? Everytime I go up to those ladders.
Like, that particular ladder there, every time I go up it,
I am a mile away from my base! In the open ocean, it's Goddamn terrifying out here! Don't do that to me.
Son of a Biscuit...
Alright, here we go.
Bubble Bumble Butt. Alright, so we're gonna make this, the pressure compensator, because we neve-- ugh, oh, my God.
Jesus. Flashing lights, no joke.
Alright, put you in this bad boy here, and boink!
Crush steps is now 300 meters. Barely what I need,
but it's enough to get by. So I'm gonna just-- I guess I'm gonna take that for what it is.
Guh guh bluh bluh bluh bluh!
Bluh bluh PBBT--- Ohhhh!
Okay, hi. Why did you do that, Mr. Warper?
Ooh, missed me by a hair!
Missed me by the hair on my chinny-chin-- you're too fast for me! Whoa whoa whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, I don't like that at all, so you can go f yourself.
Mr. Warper, who is now much more aggressive about his job... Which I would expect, the Warper is there to conta--
Wh-what did I do?!
What hurt me?
What did that? What are you talking about? Oh, I'm gonna ram you, if you're gonna be a son of a bitch,
I'm gonna ram the shit out of you, get wrecked!
BLAMP! Oh, fuck you dude. I bet that killed you.... I Bet it did.
I did some-- I did a number on my-my guy here, but he's doing okay!
He's doing alright! so I'm gonna go out and I'm gonna repair that real quick,
And then I'm gonna move on because it seems like things are
Giving me some agita!
So if I can fix the Goddamn leaks which-- oh, no.
Oh man... This makes it a lot more stressful!
Makes a lot more problematic!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, jeezums. Okay, we got that.
Oh, jeez, Goddamn, what are they doing to my boat?!
Bubble Butt, Big Box Barry...
They're doing everything to you guys... ok [I] got to get in and I got to get my gotta get Mr.
fister into the upgrade chamber because I need to upgrade...
that.
Now I fucking gotta go get eggs. I haven't even done that. I haven't even made my- God stop that!
Stop that! Oh
fine, I just need to stop going up that elevator now.
Ok, here we go.
Sploosh. oh
Use the Jets ok fire
Okay, we're almost there. Whoa whoa, whoa, whoa?
Holy shit. Oh, this is hard to control. Huh there we go ok
Nailed it in there, just by the hair on our chinny chinchin. Why is this underwater now? What the fuck did you do?
What?
What happened? What happened to my base? What did you assholes do?
What do you do?
What'd you do to my base?
Ah, fricky dick
Seems like it's out of Power suddenly. Oh
Jeez, ok, so I need the prawn suit jet upgrade which means I need
Kyanite, Sulfur, and plasteel which I think I can do and I think I have if I remember how to make kyanite
Which I believe is that material...
I believe it's not something to be made. I believe it's just that material that's in
one of my storage units because I have sulfur and I have the materials to be able to make plasteel. But man!
This is gettin'- that is getting god damned ridiculous! Oh wait. That's it,
that stuff? Kyanite. It is. Ok. So I have the kyanite. I have exactly three which is
Thankful. Oh there was more in here ok good
ok, but I'm gonna leave it in there for now, and I'm gonna make another plasteel and get when
Do okay, then I need lithium, right?
Roy! (ﾉ◕ヮ◕)ﾉ✧˖°
Roy right right there ok
Man, this is this weird. I like it. I like new I like new I gotta I'm in I like change
I do like change. Some people don't like change. Me? Me, like changing a lot
Lalala
Ok so we got the plasteel, then we just need to make these-
No, we just need to take the sulfur over then we're good to go. We're good to go
Then we're gonna get a jet upgrade on this bad boy, and that's gonna be the first step onto the new me
The whole new World that is me
For some reason this is still underwater, and I don't know- it's even higher under what what happened here? What is happening?
Why are you drowning?
Why are you drowning? This makes no sense!
What is happening to you? I don't understand
But I got this I I guess
Something is happening here
Why, it's just getting further and further underwater
This isn't right something's going on here. I
Don't even know. I don't even know man. What are the only that whoa? I thought. That was my shadow
I thought it was a creature the only thing I know that [I] oh
*whispering*what is that?
My God, when did this happen?
When did this happen? When the fuck did that happen?
They out of there gourd(wat .-.)?
The outta their Goddamn mind? Oh, I didn't even know there was gonna be damage! I
Didn't even understand that!
When did that happen?
Well are the draining systems active, or are they not? Because it seems to be not drained
Geezums. you have any Christmas- a good, good thing that all of my uh... all of my devices are waterproof
Shit. Oh there was a sploosh. Give me some oxygen here. Oh
Man, that's so weird. It must have been when my Big Box Barry like
Splooshed all over the place. Oh
Man, I need a coffee, because this very ridiculous. What? I can scan this? I have it
Why do I need to scan it?Alright, here we go. I need to scan you before I use you
Imma use ya and scan ya at the same time. There we go, coffee
Americano
Bloop. Okay, well I got that, so that's good
Okay, so I think I'm gonna have to end this episode here
I did not get everything that I wanted to get because all of this new stuff
Just punched me right in the face
But I'm gonna roll with the punches and I'm going to keep going with this so thank you everybody so much for watching
Everything that's in these new experimental builds
Bear with me and help me out. Write in the comments what I'm supposed to do and where I'm supposed to go because these new
Things are going to be rolling at us every day now and we'll see what happens
So thank you everybody so much for watching as always. I will see you in the next video. Buh-bye!
*Mr. Warper being a warperer* (ﾉ◕ヮ◕)ﾉ✧˖°